[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the span of over 70 years
fender has become a household name to
musicians all around the world
here's how they make their iconic
electric guitars
the process starts with wood selection
typically the bodies are composed of ash
or alder
but could be made with others such as
maple rosewood
ebony or mahogany depending on the
specific model
certain models come from a single block
of wood for others
two or three blocks are glued together
before cutting
an additional piece of wood is glued on
top of the neck portion
this will eventually serve as the
fretboard
specialized cutting machines cut the
shape of the body and neck
with extreme precision
throughout the process the guitar goes
through a series of critical rest
periods
in order to ensure the wood doesn't
split wood is an organic material so
you know one of the big lessons is
you've got to respect the wood and
you have to cut with precision and just
managing the wood you know from the
process of
tree to guitar and staying a guitar
to create the frets wire is cut by a
machine and then pressed into place on
the neck by a technician
next the cut parts go through a series
of sanding this process is done with a
blend of handwork and
automation if you take a look at a lot
of the work in the factory around
grinding and polishing
i mean there's a lot of hands and a lot
of shoulders and a lot of leaning into
uh
into the processing equipment so what we
try and do is really balance
and look for innovative ways to make it
safer for the employees to work more
comfortably
but also maintain the craftsmanship
aspect of
guitar manufacturing
[Music]
once the bare wood has been properly
sanded it's off to get coated in lacquer
and paint a process of which the company
considers to be a trade secret
however some of the color selections can
be linked to the early days of the
company
the guitar is reflective of the culture
at the time right so
in the early 50s we were just taking
cues from the colors
and quite honestly a lot of the paints
and paint materials the original
materials are very similar to what the
automotive industry used
the parts go through a process of
building up layers of paint then
eventually get buffed and polished to
reveal the final finish
[Music]
[Applause]
throughout this stage the sections are
hung to set and rest above the factory
floor
for anywhere between 3 and 11 days
depending on the type of paint
once the neck is attached to the body
the guitars head to final assembly
where it receives its strings and
electrical components
the pickup is a series of electromagnets
that convert the sound waves of the
string
into an electrical signal which can then
be played through an amplifier
or modified with effect pedals similar
to how a microphone senses signals from
our vocal cords
the guitar is a tool for telling stories
and i think what leo did was he listened
to
artists right so then what he was doing
was you know he was looking at different
ways to create different instruments for
artists to
kind of expand their sonic palette
fender continues to innovate with new
models like their acoustic sonic series
and their ever-growing artist signature
series
you know when you walk into the custom
shop you see some of the guitar heroes
and everyone from uh you know jimi
hendrix to stephen ray vaughan but it's
not just those guys
you know we want to make sure that we're
serving all of the folks who are
you know our buskers and emerging
songwriters and
you know just across the board you know
with great instruments great quality
and let them do what they do best